we are in the middle of a wind drought
for several days now a stiff breeze has
skirted the UK looping around from
Norway across the Atlantic but Western
Europe is there in the middle of it all
and it's almost totally calm it'll stay
like that for a while yet and that
matters because our wind farms are
almost all in Scotland and the North Sea
it's not until Wednesday or even
Thursday that the winds pick up and the
turbines start turning the lack of wind
is having a big impact on how we're
generating our electricity this has been
our Energy Mix over the last year wind
produced around 28 percent gas 42 and
coal just 1.6 but look at the mix from
lunchtime on Monday gas power stations
have been ramped up producing 61 percent
of our electricity wind is down to a
little over three percent about the same
as being generated by coal this snapshot
is unusual but it does show the
limitations of renewable energy in some
weather conditions and winds are likely
to get weaker with global warming these
are the projections on future wind
speeds even if Nations collectively
reach Net Zero soon after 2050 they drop
significantly across the Northern
Hemisphere shown by these shades of blue
a phenomenon called Global stilling and
it's caused by rapidly Rising
temperatures up in the Arctic in the UK
winds are expected to weaken by up to
three percent by 2050 and 10 percent by
the end of the century right now the UK
is taking a big bet on wind we have 14
gigawatts of onshore wind turbines and
around the same offshore but the
government has a Target to increase that
capacity to 50 gigawatts and to turn off
gas and coal power stations by 2035.
however having the turbines doesn't make
them turn as we're finding out now and
although the government also plans to
expand nuclear energy to 24 gigawatts by
2050 that wouldn't fill the gap by the
lack of wind at the moment we will need
to find some other way of storing vast
amounts of energy or importing much more
through long distance cables if we're
going to keep the lights on